okay I'm next one I try to get a be no
name wagga gambit banco gamble but in
some you went for some Queens pawn shop
off his style okay let's just try to
fianchetto the thing yeah I don't know
looks fairly good for white maybe I did
something wrong more rum already not
sure displaying really quickly I skype
we should be five if I fight once the
porn okay because I need to take it
let's hope i get enough play on the beef
on to compensate for the week a porn
yeah I think you will just develop now
we should be too
okay do I do now to exchange this Bishop
Bishop g4 don't think it will play some
useful role anyway somewhere else okay
let's exchange this thing now try to get
some play against Batum he can always
cover this with with rook a too so it's
not not super dangerous of course
and
an i don't see four would be would be a
nice piece but how to how to get get to
this always has got bishop me too
hm
don't know it's just somewhat better for
white I think we should be too now
didn't play this
don't see an active plan this is some
really annoying we cannot do much
try play for c4 c4 95 just to get some
some kind of activity cannot play we
should be too i think night c5 would
attack the rook and also a form so i
might be able to to get in down
maybe you can think of Bishop g4 just
try to to capture the Nile to capture
the night pin it okay do I have a trick
here something
looks like i should have some trick 95
Roxy for queen bee three two rooks are
hanging we cannot cover them I think I
Scott rook before rook before didn't see
this at all well let's say I saw it too
late hmm
hmm terrible time warning
maybe this will get me some activity it
takes I walk the two pieces here and
also have not a queen not be one tweenty
one check
it just blended a look there
white resigns oh this was lucky really
lucky yeah this was really this is just
an uncomfortable position like cannot do
much this Bishop here is just biting on
this pawn and then I don't think I can
do much here maybe c4 c4 here not not a
nice position computer is already on
plus 1.34 white I did think it was just
this bad but yeah I did it it's just
uncomfortable and I know the structure
he is already am already i'm already bad
or something maybe still be formed
before this should be five check and
then Bishop d7 this must be better yeah
this is just better for white I think I
don't think of some some huge
improvement hear something compared to
what i order just for the plate yeah
okay this was a lucky Whitney blundered
there okay I thanks for watching now
again this I need to get need to switch
it off yeah thanks for watching and stay
tuned for the next videos in the next
couple of days and of course comments or
questions are welcome and think of
subscribing if you didn't do that
already yeah see you Anna clear a couple
of days i think or maybe tomorrow even I
should have time